a teheran sono sempre arrivata di notte
fin da bambino impressa l'immagine del
nuovo giorno che nasce sono sul taxi
passa da piazza azadi in persiano
assenti vuol dire libertà e ogni volta
mi lascio cogliere di sorpresa da quella
torre in marmo bianco si staglia contro
il cielo che in quel momento cambia
colore mentre la capitale si sveglia
poco a poco
coach a madrid e benvenuti a teheran
queste pagine sono dedicate a voi che
avete deciso di avventurarvi in iran la
vita un viaggio viaggiare e vivere due
volte scrisse omar khayyam l'arte di
vivere l'arte di viaggiare solo lo
specchio l'una dell'altra
il viaggio è un modo per scoprire se
stessi perché finché resterà nella tua
bottega nella tua casa non sarai
veramente un uomo parti incamminati nel
mondo prima di quel giorno in cui lo
lascerà i terrà nella capitale dell'iran
a un paese grande cinque volte e mezza
l'italia tremila anni di storia non
raffinato l'anima del popolo un'anima
fiera orgogliosa della propria identità
perché scrisse d'esami se il mondo il
corpo la persia nel cuore un'anima che
trova della poesia una seconda lingua
madre
teheran una città lontana ma nemmeno
troppo e sul 35esimo parallelo nord come
l'isola di lampedusa tra teheran e il
sud italia ci sono affinità singolari
anche a teheran si dà del lei ma del voi
alle persone che non conosciamo quelle
verso cui portiamo rispetto come al sud
e come al sud per secoli le donne sono
state in posizione subalterna velate di
nero
teheran ea nord ai piedi dei monti è il
borsa un'altitudine che va dai 1.200 ai
1700 metri a primavera il cielo è nudo e
azzurro d'inverno vi si accumulano le
neve ghiaccio e neve azzurra scintillano
al sole accecando gli occhi il sole è
bevuto dai ghiacci teheran è una città
divisa le montagne a nord del deserto a
sud a nord
ab toni ricchi snobbano la repubblica
islamica e le loro donne col nasino
rifatto il trucco pesante coprono
consular soltanto parte dei capelli
mettono il chador soltanto per andare
nella città santa di qom a sud invece
vive il ceto basso provano gratitudine
verso le autorità e le loro donne
portano il chador
teheran 12 milioni di abitanti senza
contare i sobborghi 50 km di diametro
milioni di auto in circolazione l'aria è
irrespirabile teheran ha indossato la
divisa occidentale dello smog somiglia a
un posto di frontiera dell'occidente ci
passano tutti per un motivo per l'altro
e gli alberghi sono affollati di gente
che pensa di fare affari
teheran non è una città bella e come una
donna che sa di non essere bella fa buon
uso delle sue armi di seduzione terrà
nel cuore dell'iran la sua capitale
qui si decide la politica si fa
l'economia
qui vivono gli intellettuali quelli che
contano scrittori e registi artisti
gente tosta gente che non scatta gente
che non va a vivere altrove
uno dei simboli di teheran e l'attore ha
sedi imponente bizzarre marmo bianco il
primo febbraio del 79 in piazza sa di si
radunano milioni di persone celebrano i
ritorni in patria dell'ayatollah
khomeini e la rivoluzione lo scià è
scappato i rotocalchi italiani e
scrivevano spesso di lui e delle sue
mogli
la prima e faust ea sorella del re
d'egitto una venere orientale l'ovale
perfetto la carnagione pallida gli occhi
blu ma da quell'unione nasce soltanto
una bambina alla monarchia serve un
erede maschio pause a torna al cairo
la seconda moglie soraya padre iraniano
e madre tedesca ebrea di origini russe
matrimonio combinato e grande passione
si sposano nel 51 ma due anni dopo
lascia la ripudia perché non gli ha dato
figli soraya da vivere in francia decide
di fare l'attrice si innamora del
regista italiano franco indovina morto
in un incidente aereo a punta raisi
vicino a palermo
qualcuno pensa al complotto lei la
principessa triste si spegne a parigi
nel 2001 nel 59 a diventare moglie dello
scià e farà diva studia architettura
parigi si incontrano li all'ambasciata
iraniana nascono due maschi e due
femmine
il primogenito vive nel maryland
cittadino americano
suo fratello muore suicida come la
sorella leila resta farahnaz quando suo
padre fu incoronato imperatore aveva 4
anni
una bimba tre capelli scuri un diadema
di brillanti
siamo più per lo più musulmani ma lo
stiamo modo nostro perchè siamo
musulmani sciiti a teheran ci sono
chiese sinagoghe perché rispetto per le
altre fedi è storia antica e forse la
dissimulazione l'abbiamo imparato dagli
ebrei dalla loro regina esser è orfana
ebrea grazie allo zio da sposa al re
persiano dissimula la propria fede
quando il visir condanna a morte gli
ebrei ne ottiene la liberazione vicende
narrate nella bibbia nel libro di esser
esser dissimula per salvare i suoi in
caso di pericolo anche noi sciiti
dobbiamo dissimulare perché come recita
un proverbio se a mezzogiorno re dice
che notte fonda su contempla le stelle
forse è stata lei a essere a insegnarci
ad adattare la verità le circostanze di
simulare torna utile di fronte alle
difficoltà di fronte agli integralismi
reagiamo un po di simulando un po con
l'estetica della sovversione recitando
versi di oggi sul nostro poeta del
trecento contemporaneo di dante
se solo le porte delle taverne potessero
essere riaperte se solo i nodi delle
misure repressive potessero essere
sciolti tu sii paziente per volere di
dio riapriranno riapriranno grazie alla
purezza dei bevitori mattutini stanno
chiudendo le porte delle taverne ma tu
dio non concedere la tua approvazione
perché così apriranno le porte
dell'ipocrisia
la persia è un paese senza tempo il suo
nome evoca incanti molteplici moschee
minareti gemme di architettura giardini
rigogliosi maestose rovine che parlano
di un passato splendido si ergono tra
solitudini desertiche tende vagabonde
quella persiana e una bellezza terribile
ogni fresco fiore che adorna questa
aiuola se lo guardi e una rosa sì lo
coglie una spina l'ha persa è un paese
in transizione tra passato e presente
teheran non è né oriente e occidente il
punto di incontro di civilta contigue
indipendenti ma è diversa è l'emblema
della schizofrenia culturale degli
iraniani sospesi tra oriente e occidente
teheran è una città con due anime una
città in cui si vive
sospesi tra modernità e tradizione
siamo cittadini di una repubblica
islamica e la nostra dovrebbe essere una
democrazia religiosa ma in realtà è una
oligarchia di ayatollah e pasdaran un
regime è per certi versi totalitario una
cultura non omologata
a noi donne di teheran e piace fare
sport al tempo dello scià le atlete in
pantaloncini o minigonna davano
l'immagine di un paese moderno ma erano
un tassello nella propaganda di regime
certo praticare sport e rispettando le
regole della repubblica islamica non è
facile aresu si allenava nelle piscine
di teheran negli orari riservati alle
donne ma la legge iraniana le ha
impedito di mostrarsi in costume alle
olimpiadi di londra ha reso non si è
data per vinta e muta leggere foulard è
salita sul kayak e a eton è arrivata
settima sciare acida un gran senso di
libertà andiamo divina jean jacques poco
lontano da teheran e località affollate
viba cena nei figli di papà sullo
snowboard e le ragazze truccate come se
dovessero andare a una festa sulle piste
ci si incontra ci si dà appuntamento km
chilometri di piste innevate
non sempre la polizia riesce a
controllarci tante osano sciare senza
foulard per questo la polizia religiosa
vorrebbe impedire l'accesso agli
impianti di risalita alle giovani donne
non accompagnate da un parente e già
nella repubblica islamica c'è una
polizia religiosa
le donne di teheran
conoscete scirin ebadi il nostro nobel
per la pace
avete letto persepolis di marjane
satrapi leggere lolita a teheran
gli ha fatto capire le nostre tante
difficoltà i vostri giornali scrivono di
noi hanno scritto di neda uccisa durante
le manifestazioni del movimento verde e
di sakineh condannata alla lapidazione
una condanna sospesa grazie alle
pressioni occidentali ma non sempre i
vostri giornali scrivono che in iran
la scuola è gratuita e obbligatoria fino
a 14 anni i bambini e le bambine vanno a
scuola non passano le giornate a tessere
tappeti il lavoro minorile è vietato il
pomeriggio non vanno alla scuola
coranica di religione ne abbiamo fin
sopra i capelli
all'università due matricole su tre sono
donne
nel 2006 il governo ha imposto le quote
azzurre per dare uguali opportunità ai
ragazzi nelle facoltà di medicina
odontoiatria e farmacia abbiamo riso ma
poi le cose sono peggiorate le autorità
stanno imponendo la segregazione dei
sessi nelle università
da noi è cosa nuova perché quando fu
inaugurata all'università di teheran nel
1937 potevano iscriversi uomini e donne
e sedersi vicini l'unica università
femminile risale al 1964 l'aveva voluta
lo scià voleva imitare gli stati uniti
gli le università femminili e ci sono e
sono anche prestigiose da noi no sono
una novità priva di senso che cosa
studiamo maschi e femmine preferiamo le
facoltà scientifiche
vogliamo diventare medici ingegneri
informatici solo l'otto per cento
frequenta facoltà umanistiche perché con
una laurea in lettere con bini poco i
guadagni
ancor meno tutto è più finisce a fare
l'insegnante
i diritti delle donne sono una battaglia
continua abbiamo il diritto di voto dal
1963 il suffragio universale ce l'aveva
dato lo scià l'ayatollah khomeini non ha
potuto toglierlo ma il diritto di voto
non basta fare una democrazia barometro
della democrazia sono i diritti delle
donne i diritti delle minoranze
religiose ed etniche i diritti di coloro
che hanno un diverso orientamento
sessuale
per la legge della repubblica islamica
dell'iran noi donne vogliamo la metà
rispetto a un uomo quando ereditiamo
quando testimoniamo in tribunale quando
siamo vittime di violenze ci spetta un
risarcimento
la poligamia è permessa in iran ma a
determinate condizioni a dare il
permesso sono le prime moglie
difficilmente accettano compromessi ma
se sposiamo uno straniero non possiamo
dare la nostra cittadinanza iraniana e i
figli un diritto che voi italiani avete
ottenuto nel 1983 ottenere il divorzio
poi non è facile la custodia dei figli
non sempre ci viene concessa il fatto di
diritti dovremo dare retta al nostro
poeta offese sa brava safar ardo gustare
academy of fund
bisogna avere pazienza perché chi non ha
pazienza non ha saggezza in questi anni
tanto è cambiato i nostri tassi di
fertilità sono simili a quelli italiani
non si arriva alla media di due figli e
poi i diritti sono un percorso ostacoli
ma con voi non mi piace fare la vittima
non voglio lamentarmi delle tante
difficoltà anche perché poco alla volta
otteniamo qualche risultato con un
pizzico di creatività come la mia amica
lei la suo marito non voleva concedere
il divorzio allora cercato di comprarlo
rinunciando al meglio una cifra che la
famiglia il mullah che celebra le nozze
inseriscono nel contratto di matrimonio
e quindi ha valore legale
il m e è il prezzo della sposa e una
somma denaro monete d'oro oppure perfino
un immobile che il marito deve pagare
per la verginità della sposa anche in
seconda no
è una formalità di fatto è il prezzo del
divorzio genitori per bene non darebbero
mai la loro figliola in sposa senza
garantirle la giusta protezione in caso
di divorzio in un sistema sociale in cui
la donna è quasi sempre perdente dal
punto di vista legale
tanto più che una divorziata senza
rendite è solo una divorziata mentre se
economicamente indipendente allora è una
signora lui ti vuole deve dimostrare di
essere generoso non c'è lui la peggio di
un uomo spilorcio in ogni caso tu donna
6 superiore al denaro non sai caso non
esige il pagamento immediato ci penserai
soltanto se un giorno lui chiederà il
divorzio un modo per dissuaderlo dal
mollarti senza essersi fatto due conti
perché in iran doyle metri e indicizzato
al tasso di inflazione
lo dice dalla legge della repubblica
islamica tuo marito ti lascia dopo
vent'anni ti deve gli interessi lui
mollare tu glielo dice chiaro e tondo ti
renderò la vita impossibile meglio sia
tu a lasciarmi libera in cambio se una
signore paghi per la tua libertà
rinunciando al prezzo della sposa e poi
hai paura di restare sola
moscherini 16 la mia amica non ti
preoccupare alisan là fuori il mondo è
pieno di uomini pronti a sposarti
sposarti ha tempo per qualche mese per
un anno poi magari rinnovi ancora per un
po ti stanchi prima della scadenza
scioglie il contratto in anticipo si
chiama site
e una cosa tutta sciita tutta persiana
incoraggiata dal clero è il matrimonio a
tempo volto a dare sfogo ai desideri
sessuali perché da noi la sessualità non
è un tabù
a patto che sia consumata all'interno di
un qualche matrimonio
frano l'unione ha tempo e una delle
tante contraddizioni della repubblica
islamica
il matrimonio vero e proprio star
d'affari figli
il site
a soddisfare il desiderio e ai suoi
vantaggi
se ti sposi a tempo ognuno abita a casa
propria non gli devi lavare i calzini e
non sei tenuta a dirlo i tuoi può essere
un'unione segreta al suo fascino perché
come recita un adagio il sun bayadh mesi
le nove chef xavi adobe era la donna
deve essere come la luna appare la sera
e se ne va
al mattino
donne teheran e come ogni shahrzad
sussurra le parole giuste incanta il suo
interlocutore e incanterà anche voi se
deciderete di viaggiare e come miniera
di rubini sarete aperti all'influsso dei
raggi del sole
il tempo a nostra disposizione sta per
terminare potrei raccontarvi le
avventure del libro dei re di fergus le
avventure ambientate sul monte da amava
avventure di cui mi narrava mia nonna
marian nella poesia persiana quella cima
è un demone bianco
la leggenda racconta di un drago atleta
s simbolo del male in cante nato sulle
pendici battute dal vento e condannato
restarvi in attesa della fine del mondo
per i persiani il dama wanda il simbolo
della resistenza ai dominatori stranieri
e la vetta più alta del medio oriente un
cono di ghiaccio un monte che vulcano la
sua cima spicca solitaria innevata nord
est di teheran al tramonto baciato dal
sole e un tizzone rosio nel cielo sempre
più scuro nonna marian e mi raccontava
di temine figlia del re del sistan sposa
di rostan il più grande eroe dell'iran
etico dal loro amore nasce sohrab cresce
con la mamma perché rossa me parte il
giorno dopo le nozze mai visto il figlio
temine il simbolo della donna che sola
cresce suo figlio insegnandogli l'amore
per un padre che non c'è né con noi
donne di teheran e siamo redi di temine
eppure di sé e del cir in male che katun
combattiva sagace reggente al posto del
figlio troppo giovane per diventare re
e ora lasciatemi dire un'ultima cosa
come recita il mistico rumi la verità è
uno specchio caduto dalle mani di dio è
andato in frantumi ogni pezzo
restituisce a chi lo tiene soltanto una
parte di verità se la verità è uno
specchio dato in frantumi
in queste pagine vi ho consegnato
soltanto un frammento il frammento della
mia a teheran